you're in need of some good ideas as far
as gifts go wellness and lifestyle coach
seema cohen is sharing her ultimate gift
guide for the whole family take a look
hello las vegas now happy holidays i'm
so happy to be here today to share my
holiday gift guide for the whole family
i absolutely love this brand of olive
oils and vinegars breitlin is a female
founded small business started in la
that partners with and supports local
independent family-run california farms
to make craft olive oil and vinegars
brightland is focused on clean
production and high standards to make
sure the oils and vinegars are super
fresh taste amazing and are better for
you with extra high antioxidants
brightline is the perfect gift for its
beautiful packaging and because it
encourages healthier living you will
test the difference compared to what you
already have at home and you can find
them at brightland.com
all right parents i got you perfect gift
chili child is a wearable blanket pancho
for babies and toddlers developed by a
mom who was looking for an easy solution
for every day's obstacles the wearable
blankets are reversible made in the u.s
patent-pending and water resistant no
more flooring blankets in car seats and
no more hustling with zippers on wiggly
baby chili chai is not just a cute
fashion item but also a highly
functional outerwear piece a perfect
gift for parents on your list and you
can find them at chilichild.com
all right one of my favorite sushi is an
organic cold pressed non-gmo juice
company best in san diego california
they carry a wide variety of juices
wellness shots and now their new edition
of sushi organic elements a refreshing
line of sparkling cold pressed juice
blends carbonated to perfection that
delivers the ultimate wellness boost you
can receive a monthly subscription of
sushi when you subscribe online through
sushijuice.com
and you can also find them at vans
albertsons kroger walmart target whole
foods trader joe's and even costco
okay skin lovers i got you covered
dickinson's poor perfecting toner is
america's number one selling toner it
refreshes skin and refines pores removes
excess oil dirt and makeup residue
without over drying this 100 natural
toner is made with dickinson's plain to
bottle process that uses
sustainably harvested certified organic
witch hazel plants that are distilled
for purity and performance capturing the
botanical scent in a toner gentle enough
for sensitive skin for daily use
dickinson's poor perfecting toner is the
perfect holiday gift for stocking
stuffer or for skin anybody that is in
love with skin care you can find them at
major retailers and on amazon.com
all right sadaf sadaf is a family-owned
company that's been around for almost 40
years they take pride in producing
chef-inspired kitchen and pantry items
that are wholesome and as close to
homemade as possible they carry unique
items that you can find anywhere else
and they also ship nationwide cozy up
this winter season we set up organic tea
you can add organic honey and cinnamon
sticks which make a perfect holiday
treat absolutely love that for anybody
that is foodie or chef inspired on your
list and you can find them at sagaf.com
happy holidays